[Musique]
de plus en plus d'amateurs de pizzas
cherche à reproduire à la maison la
cuisson parfaite du four à bois du
restaurant aujourd'hui on vous livre les
résultats de notre banc d'essai nous
testons 6 pierre et plaques à pizza avec
stéphane la jeunesse épicurien et
boulanger à matin et alexandre brunet
créateur des pizzas stromboli
aujourd'hui copropriétaire des pizzerias
900 on a la chance d'avoir une partie
doit être uniforme d'une recette qui va
être parfait
donc on va vraiment voir la performance
des pierres la croûte doit être
croustillantes sans être sèche et cuite
uniformément
c'est peut-être la beauté de la maison
oblige les parfaites toutes les pizzas
sont cuites de la même façon dix minutes
à 500 degrés on est d'abord là ricardo
encore dit reed préchauffé 40 minutes
tel que demandé
alexandre utilise un papier parchemin
pour faciliter le transfert de l'appel à
la pierre chaude
le parchemin et retiré après une minute
aux petites finitions
aussant à la lune à l'oeil la fête
mais était-ce pas moins que comme en
uniforme c'est aussi bien votre stylo
que dans le milieu on peut voir ici les
alvéoles en fait on peut les voir ici
sont vraiment très très belle deuxième
pierrelatte inc est une latine kitchen
préchauffer 15 minutes
la comptable a un peu mieux que la
première dans ce cas est le plus coloré
donc on fait le test du groupe swing au
simple on l'a entendu c'était moins
croustillantes et moi j'ai quand même un
bon résultat vous dis oui oui c'est un
bon résultat mais on voit que c'est
effectivement c'est moins uniforme le
centre si plus humide conciliables pas
le temps de sécher correctement place
aux deux pierres email d'abord la emile
envie enfin notre finition tout le côté
vraiment vraiment très uniforme
oui très bien cuit oui on précis sont
fait que les pizzas à la même
température et le même temps qu'une fois
la levée en ag est bon mais ça que c'est
beaucoup plus sec que les deux hommes
avaient de la peine quand la sorte à 120
dans la lah lagostina est de loin la
plus chère du lot la coloration est
belle on dirait que le monde poursuit un
peu plus concentré c'est comme si la
chaleur est peut-être plus intense parce
que ça fait c'est que la rapporte à push
- il semble être plus raide comme
celle-là sèche est plutôt de la guérir
encore une fois c'est une question de
goût mais moi je préfère que les crous
yade à l'extérieur et moelleux à
l'intérieur
à ceux-ci cruciaux ici c'est que la
porte à la peau vraiment cuit je pense
que côté mailly ce qui se passe c'est
que dès qu'on dépose la piste sur la
pierre la charge doit de se dégager ils
trop vite sur la porte donc
quand un sèche place à la plaque en
acier l'a vraiment qu'un petit ces
cercles la coloration
c'est probablement l'un des plus beaux
ils te prenais kikuchi mais encore un
peu raide mais ce n était qu un petit
affaires de moine je pense que le
résultat est vraiment été très
intéressant le pire résultat de notre
test et la plaque en aluminium de marque
crown ya aucune tenue on peut le voir il
ya zéro tenue
c'est vraiment très très liquide ça
c'est décevant
mise à part celle ci nos experts ont
trouvé que toutes les pierres ont donné
d'assez bons résultats mais ils ont
leurs préférés j'aurais tendance à aller
vers la gare d'eau c'est celle que
produit la croûte les plus tendres dû à
son épaisseur la porosité
je pense que c'est ce qui est le plus
similaire un four de restaurants seul
bémol on doit la préchauffé 40 minutes
alexandre et stéphane ont également
choisi la vraiment casting pour sa
performance sa résistance aux chocs et
sa polyvalence car on peut aussi
l'utiliser sur le barbecue pour cuire
autre chose que des pizzas
je pense qu'avec un peu de fignolage
cessez le feu
vraiment donné le résultat le plus
proche de 50
[Rires]